fabrice di vizio avocat spécialiste des
médecins libéraux
bonjour fabrice di vizio merci d'être
alerté france votre cabinet d'avocats a
donc annoncé avoir saisi la cour de
justice de la république
vous attaquez agnès buzyn edouard
philippe au nom d'un collectif
professionnel de sorte de santé qu'est
ce que vous attendez exactement de la
justice on va donc deux choses de la
justice la première c'est d'abord que la
vérité soit faite
c'est à dire que madame busin nous a
expliqué qu'elle savait elle a eu ce
besoin impérieux de se confesser
dans dix ans je savais tout tout le
monde savait tout le monde savait le
tsunami ou soul et du terme qui allait
déferler sur la france je les suis très
tôt j'ai averti tout le monde mais rien
n'a été fait bon eh ben ça ça s'appelle
une négligence coupable si la loi pénale
une abstention volontaire constitue une
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
d'abstention volontaire c'est vraiment
le coeur même du bras pédales et donc ce
que nous attendons la sécurité soient
dites que vous pleurez min soit
interrogé que les scientifiques soient
interrogés que les mails soient saisis
madame du zinc dit qu'elle a envoyé un
mail à monsieur le président de la
république à monsieur emmanuel macron et
bien je veux ce mail je veux qu'elle
justice saisie ce mail et qu'on sache
qui est responsable et coupable
vous parlez donc d'agnès bizien d'il ya
donc lors d'un entretien au monde
d'exprimer son mea culpa je vais redire
la phrase je savais que la vague du
tsunami était devant nous c'est donc la
phrase de l'ancien ministre de la santé
donc faute à 2000 pardonner ou bien
est-ce que vous souhaiter une sanction
exemplaire en lien avec la crise
sanitaire
moi je suis avocat j'ai l'habitude de
ces questions de santé publique ce que
je souhaite d'abord c'est qu'une
sanction soit prise parce que personne
ne peut arriver dans la presse en pleine
campagne d'épidémie comme on l'a connu
comme on la connaît à ce pont en ce
moment et venir dire
bon bah écoute et voilà alors j'ai
besoin de le confesser
j'ai mal fait non il n'y a pas de faute
avouée à demi pardonnée au contraire la
vue de cette faute caractérise de
l'infraction pénale et madame du
et doublement coupable même triplement
coupable elle est coupable ne rien à
voir dit elle est coupable de ne rien
avoir fait et elle est coupable en
pleine crise sanitaire majeure devenir
effectivement avoir ce besoin impérieux
de se confesser
et si elle espère que cette confession
qui vise à soulager sa conscience
et puis pourrait avoir un effet
finalement j'ai presque envie de dire
miséricordieux c'est exactement le
contraire
madame busin signe son irresponsabilité
et dès lors sa culpabilité majeur mais
cela étant c'est un secret de
polichinelle
mes clients tout ce qui fonde la santé
publique que mon cabinet savent depuis
le départ qu'en fait cette affaire a été
étouffée et depuis le départ savent
qu'en réalité il suffit de lire le
rapport de l' oms du 30 janvier pour
savoir que les déclarations de la dame
busin ne sont pas en conformité avec le
rapport de l' oms je suis juste soulagé
et heureux qu'elle le reconnaisse enfin
parce que maintenant on va pouvoir du
coup se lancer dans une bataille pénale
donc il faut qu'on ressorte absolument
vainqueur pour le besoin de la santé
publique et pour les besoins de santé
des populations
alors justement parler de bataille
pénale comment est ce que vous comptez
prouver le motif je cite de négligence
coupable du premier ministre et de l'ex
ministre de la santé le gouvernement dit
s'appuyer sur les avis des meilleurs
scientifiques et des meilleurs experts
pour prendre cette décision non alors je
file me répondre deux choses d'abord
j'ai rien à prouver du tout pour la
raison suivante c'est que la preuve elle
est toute faite à partir de lambada mme
buzyn déclare qu' elle a alerté le
président de la république par mail elle
a alerté par mail elle bien
donc elle dit qu'elle a envoyé un
message le contenu de ce message porte
m'apparaît tout à fait fondamental ça
c'est le premier point
deuxième point c'est que madame d'uzein
dit j'ai averti le premier ministre
très bien eh ben c'est intéressant de
savoir ce qu elle a dit au premier
ministre il faut qu'elles soient
auditionnés et que près ministre
également
enfin dernier point le gouvernement dit
on s'est appuyé sur les meilleurs
experts scientifiques
bah alors très bien moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'aller voir ce qu'on
dit exactement ces experts scientifiques
parce que moi j'ai la preuve que le
gouvernement ment rapport à ces experts
scientifiques il l'a fait récemment
propos des municipales il a menti sur ce
qu'ont dit les scientifiques ça c'est
une troisième point et enfin j'ai envie
de vous dire allez lire il faut que
madame busin jeu philippe à élire le
rapport de l' oms du 30 janvier
le 30 janvier le ms déclare une urgence
sanitaire international c'est la sixième
fois depuis 1964 dit qu'il ya dix mille
cas dans le monde sachant qu'il y en a
forcément plus puisque la chine a un
petit peu voilà attendu pour donner ces
chiffres dont il déclare même pas au
bout d'un mois l'urgence sanitaire
atteint nationale disons que le virus
circule et madame busoni dit le
contraire il faut pas être effectivement
au parloir fait 15 ans d'études pour
voir que c'est la vie qui priment solide
oms donc si le gouvernement a choisi
d'ignorer la ville de ms pour s'appuyer
sur les recommandations de ces
scientifiques dont j'ignore qu'ils sont
eh ben c'est son problème mais madame du
sahel
manifestement a choisi de s'appuyer sur
l'avis de l'om est puisqu'elle a alerté
le gouvernement dit elle c'est ce qu'il
faudra effectivement précisé qu at elle
dit qu at elle écrit
et pourquoi est ce que personne ne sait
comment dirais-je pourquoi personne ne
s'est fié aux recommandations de l'om
est ce aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya un
conseil de défense liées à cette crise
sanitaire
à quoi est-ce que vous vous attendez à
ce que les mesures que le collectif ces
19 que vous défendez vont être prises
selon vous mais on ne s'attend
absolument plus à rien sinon au pire
vous avez à faire un gouvernement de
menteur qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
enfin pardonnez moi mais à un moment
donné il faut être honnête
ces gens vous demandent depuis le début
et ils vous mentent sur les chiffres
j'ai entendu le directeur général de la
santé tout à l'heure vous dire voilà les
chiffres mais rime à quoi ces chiffres
on teste plus les gens ça fait un mois
pour les tests plus on n'a plus les
moyens de les tester
le nombre de cas qui sont suspectes kovy
de plus mais conteste pas faute de
moyens faute deux fautes de test il faut
qu'on arrête de prendre les français
pour des imbéciles à un moment donné on
a affaire d'un gouvernement de menteur
donc qu'est-ce que j'en attends mais on
va encore prendre quelques mesures on va
encore faire un efet comme en bien de
vous expliquer qu' il faut faire ceci ou
faire cela mais la mairie
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le retard qu'on a
pris ne se rattrapera jamais regarder
vous voulez un exemple le gouvernement
la semaine dernière a dit que les
masques que vous souvenez de ces de ses
allocutions grandiloquent de monsieur le
président de la république qui vous
expliquer avec un ton très martial d'un
général en chef des armées que les
masques allait arriver
les masques c'est quand même le nerf de
la guerre pour protéger les et des
professionnels de santé
ils sont arrivés ces masques ils sont
ces masques ou est-ce qu'ils sont ces
masques aujourd'hui concrètement
moi j'ai des médecins qui sont
contaminés tous les jours alors oui on a
fait l'aumône en envoyant quelques
masques haute on a un gros 18 par
semaine par an par médecin
ce qui représente on peut tenir trois
jours avec ça on change de masse que
toutes les trois heures et le directeur
général de la santé un phénomène en
appelant les particuliers à 2 mais leur
masque professionnels de santé ou alors
est-ce qu'on en est on en est au fait
que ce gouvernement a choisi de mettre
en danger la vie de ses soignants et la
vie des populations choisi et bien
pardonnez moi de l'expression de
caviarder les chiffres en venant
occulter le fait que plus personne
quasiment des des pistes et saufs
suite à l'article de la mort où vous
êtes député donc ce qu'on attend ce
gouvernement c'est plus rien aujourd'hui
je vais vous dire je suis extrêmement
pessimiste sur les chances de succès à
court terme de vaincre ce virus la seule
chose que j'espère c'est que mes clients
espèrent médecin c'est que le
confinement marchera à peu près parce
que bon je veux bien un confinement
total 95 le syndicat des internes
excusez moi mais mon cher pas qu'on
s'est transformé en chine mise à part si
vous mettez un gendarme d'avoir chaque
porte
ça marchera pas c'est impossible conseil
d'état peut pas valider sa de soi ce que
parce que la requête est irrecevable
merci merci à fabrice di vizio d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes donc avocat spécialiste des
médecins libéraux